こんばんは。
８時になりました、ニュースをお伝えします。
今日未明、静岡市在住の自称動画クリエイター”はじめしゃちょー”の
巨大なグミ を食べるだけのしょうもない動画が
再生回数1億回を突破した疑いがあることが分かりました。
（はさみを箱にぶっ刺す音）
ご覧いただいているこの映像は、
2015 年7 月に江田容疑者が実際に投稿し た動画です。
このしょうもない動画は、去年12月ごろから世界各地で再生回数が激増したとみられ
現在も再生回数が伸びている模様です。
この状況に対し江田容疑者は、
と、話しています。
ミュージック ビデオ以外のYouTube動画 で1億回再生突破は
静岡県内で初、
YouTuberのしょうもない動画としては
日本初の記録とみられています。
統計によりますと、この動画が最も再生された日は
去年、2018年12月15日で
1日で118万回再生されたということです。
この記録は、動画の公開日からおよそ2 年3ヵ月ぶりの快挙になり ます。
これに対し江田容疑者は、
と、話しています。
また、この変なグミを食べるだけのしょうもない動画の再生地域を見てみる と
日本以外 のインド、ベトナム、ブラジル、インドネシアなど
暑いイメージのある地域で、3割以上の再生回数を占めています。
この結果を受けて、一部の関係者からは
「はじめしゃちょーがインド人ではないか？」
と、 国籍詐称を指摘する声が上がり、
これに対して江田容疑者は、
と、容疑を否認しているということです。
番組では、容疑者が1億回再生を突破した瞬間の貴重な映像を独占入手しました。
け）はじめさんっ
け）はじめさんっはじめさんっ
け）あ、痛っ
け）はじさんっはじさんっ…はじさｎ…
ｱﾅ）ご覧いただいている映像は今朝6時ごろ、
ｱﾅ）静岡市内にある容疑者の自宅にて撮影された映像です。
ｱﾅ）事件当時、容疑者は熟睡しており意識がなく、
ｱﾅ）と、供述しています。
さぁそして、ここで速報が入ってきました。
たった今、容疑者のはじめしゃちょーが現場に現れたようです。
中継が繋がっています、現場の田中さん。
はい、こちら中継の田中です。
容疑者のはじめしゃちょーと中継が繋がっております。
は）よろしくお願いします…あ、お願いします…
ｱﾅ）はじめさん、まずは再生回数1億回突破、おめでとうございます。
は）あ、もう繋がっている…？
田中）あ、はい。
は）あぁ…
は）あ、はいぃ
は）あっありがとうございます
ｱﾅ）続いてなんですけれども、あの1億回突破した瞬間の気持ち、いかがだったでしょうか。
は）…繋がってます？
田中）繋がってますね。
は）えぇ？…あ、あー…
は）そうですね、はい
は）いやーもう
は）あんな動画で1億回行くー…
は）と思ってなかったんでびっくりしました
ｱﾅ）そしてですね、最後に今後の目標について聞かせてください。
は）え、繋がってますぅ？
田中）はい。
は）…あーはい、
は）あ、今後の目標…そうですねー
は）まぁ1億回…今回行ったんですけども、
は）”この動画だけ”っては思わず
は）次の動画…なんか別の動画もですね、1億回…
は）行ったり、こう…そういうの2本3本って たくさん今後
は）出せていければいいなと思ってます
ｱﾅ）ありがとう ござい ます。最後にですね、あのもう一 つだけ、あのーはじめさん
ｱﾅ）一部関係者からですね、
ｱﾅ）「はじめしゃちょーはインド人だったんではないか」
ｱﾅ）と、そういう声が上がっているんですが
ｱﾅ）実際のところどうなんでしょう？
は）いやインド人じゃねーわ。